okay so um let's continue so this is
actually in some sense a key breaking
point in the course which is in such
that's what we've done so far is give
you a set of tools to understand how to
think about how consumers and producers
make decisions and then to understand
how you compare positive and normative
implications of economics what we're
gonna do for the rest of the class for
the rest of the semester
is we're gonna start talk about how you
apply those tools to more realistic
situations let me into your very first
question what you learned today is not
on the midterm okay
so that's the question no it's all in
your mind because it is so the midterm
tomorrow night will cover everything
through through what we covered through
last week but we learned today will not
be on the midterm but don't leave
because it will be on the final and it
is interesting so what we're gonna do
today is talk about taking the tools we
developed so far in this class and
applying to more realistic situations
and the more realistic situation we're
going to start with is the case of
monopolies and we're going to talk about
monopoly profit maximization now so far
on the producer side we've been
discussing one extreme of how the
markets organized which is perfect
competition and perfect competition is a
wonderful sort of theoretical benchmark
but never actually exists in reality no
market is perfectly competitive the
other extreme is not widely applicable
but still does exist in reality which is
monopoly okay
monopoly is a situation where a market
only has one firm in it so a market with
one firm is a monopoly market okay so so
that's basically a case where you have
only one firm providing the good okay
now in reality most markets fall between
perfect competition which never truly
exists and monopoly which rarely exists
most markets are in between we call them
oligopolies that's markets with several
several firms but not perfectly
competing and we'll get to that but
that's
one of the harder things we'll cover so
we're gonna start with this other
extreme of Monopoly which gives us a lot
of the insights we need for oligopoly
but in a much simpler case now the key
thing with monopoly the key difference
from what we've done so far is that now
firms are gonna be price makers not
price takers that's gonna be the key
change from the part of the competitive
situation perfectly competitive
situation from any given firms
perspective the price is something given
them by the great market okay we talked
with our two diagrams side by side about
how the market gives the price but we
sort of from any given perspective they
were a price taker
they couldn't affect the price
monopolist however when you're the only
firm you get to set the price so
monopolist are gonna be price makers not
price takers and that's what would
that's gonna change the dynamics of
everything we do and that'll be our
focus today okay so that's gonna be the
big the big change will go for
competitive markets - monopoly markets
okay now for the first two-thirds or
three-quarters of the lecture we're
gonna make one other assumption we are
gonna assume there is one price in this
market that is no price discrimination
this monopolist sets the price but he
sets one price for everybody so Van
AAPIs is selling a good they sell that
at one price too everybody buys the good
now once again this is not super
realistic monopolist often have
different price for goods but it's a
it's a very important helpful extreme
and you got to remember that we're
imposing this constraint cuz it's gonna
drive the intuition I'm gonna come to
next okay so you're a firm selling good
at one price you offer it up anybody can
buy it at that price okay now what we're
gonna do if you remember I'm gonna up
the fundamental part of consumer of
producer that holds is the gold
monopolist is to Max's profit maximizes
profits
okay which is revenues minus costs and
as we showed before profits are
maximized when
marginal revenue equals marginal cost
that's the profit maximization point now
nothing on the cost side is going to
change so monopolist monopolist but the
way we get cost curves doesn't change
that's all about remember because that
just comes the technology of production
and that comes from input prices okay so
nothing on the cost side is gonna change
all that hard and somewhat boring work
we did deriving cost functions and stuff
that all is that's done the only place
monopoly gets exciting is on the
marginal revenue side because before we
said marginal revenue is just price for
a price taker but that's no longer true
margin remember is no longer just price
now Marg remedies can be more
interesting
so the monopoly difference if you will
or the imperfect competition difference
doesn't come at all from the cost side
that side is done doesn't matter what
kind of market you're looking at okay
all the interesting action here is on
the revenue side as we think about
Monopoly and oligopoly markets okay so
to think about that let's go to figure
eleven one okay think about let's start
by thinking about a competitive firm
this is a diagram I could have shown
earlier it just sort of is the way to
think about a competitive firm think
about a competitive firms profits so
imagine that um this firm to make life
easy let's imagine that um we have a
firm with marginal cost to zero okay so
you've got demand curve and so therefore
any money you make is profit and we're
in the short-run
okay so there's profit in the short-run
even for this perfectly competitive firm
but a perfectly competitive firm face
the horizontal demand curve so if they
sell Q units okay they make profits of
area a which is simply Q times P one
little Q times P one if they sell Q plus
one units they make an extra profit
rectangle of B so literally the marginal
the extra profit they make is just the
amount P it's
1 times P 1 the the horizontal distance
from Q to Q plus 1 is 1 the vertical
distance is P 1 so the marginal profit
is just the price ok marginal revenue
I'm sorry it's just a price yeah what is
it in the short-run there can be right
in the short-run there can be profited
market in the long run there's no profit
ok so basically their marginal revenue
what they make that next unit they make
is the price ok now let's think about a
monopoly firm a monopoly firm does not
face a perfectly elastic demand curve
because a monopoly firms demand curve is
the whole market notice little Q has
become big Q on the x axis the
monopolist no longer faces only their
perfectly elastic firm demand they face
a market demand which can be aim degree
of elasticity but typically is somewhat
elastic it's downward sloping now let's
say your monopolist and you're selling
big Q units at a price p1 your rep your
profits are C plus a once again that's a
marginal cost of 0 to make this easy RC
plus a now let's say you want to sell
one more unit well what's different
what's different is now you're facing a
downward sloping demand curve so if you
want to sell one more unit you have to
lower the price that's the difference if
you want to sell another unit you can
only do so by lowering the price and
your a price maker so you have to rate
to do that so if you want to sell
another unit two things are gonna happen
a you were gonna sell a second unit and
make money on that unit that's the area
B but B I guess a 1 into 1 you sell a
second year that's the area B 2 you will
lose money on all the other units you
sold because now you have to lower the
price because remember there's only one
price okay so basically you used to make
a plus C now you make a plus B you've
added B but you've lost C so what is the
margin
revenue the modular monopolist is now
the area B mines the area C or p2 which
is area B 1 times P 2 minus P 2 minus P
1 minus P 2 times Q 0 the original
quantity okay this is the area C but
this is the area B the original quantity
times the change in price so your Mars
revenue is not this simple just price
for and more now it's this more
complicated term okay
more generally marginal revenue can be
defined as the marginal revenue is
defined as marginal revenue is defined
as P plus Delta P Delta Q times Q that's
marginal revenue okay the first term is
positive that's the money you make on
the next unit the second term is
negative because by definition the dam
may encourage downward sloping where
there's no given goods anymore in this
class demand may be on a test but not in
reality the demand curves downward
sloping okay so this term is negative
now once again I'm writing Delta but
really its derivative so this is all
increment this is all this is sort of
epsilon changes this is Q zero okay this
is sort of epsilon changes but the
bottom lines for an epsilon change in
price you get for an epsilon change in
quantity you get the the price on the
unit you sell - the money lost the news
you can no longer sell okay this is the
key intuition a monopoly math they can't
yeah
this is your marginal revenue I just did
it graphically that's that's that that's
your marginal revenue you just see that
from the graph okay I just rewrote it
here okay
so base or for those of you into
calculus if you just differentiate just
if those who are who are who have your
calculus you just write you know
DRD to do you revenue DQ okay what do
you get you get P plus DP DQ times Q
that's just the derivative of the rep of
revenue with respect to quantity okay so
let's think and tula what's going on
here this is very very important what's
going on here is to sell another unit
you have to lower your price you're
working away down your demand curve and
therefore it offsets the benefit you get
from selling another unit okay I liked I
like to call this the poisoning effect I
mean it's not original to me but it's a
term that I've heard use that I like the
poisoning effect the idea is that to
sell another unit I have to poison
myself a little bit by lowering the
price at all the previous units I sold
okay if I want to go out in the market
and force consumers to buy one more unit
I've got to lower the price on all the
units which offsets money I used to make
so that's why we call it a sort of
poisoning effect now why doesn't a
competitive firm face this issue why we
just bringing this up now why does the
monopoly firm face of poisoning effect a
competitive firm does it or I'll turn
another one ask the question is in what
situation monopoly firm not face a
poisoning effect yeah
but they're not
but that's X all right the competitive
firms a price taker but in particular
even even though the price taker Y when
they sell more quantity is there no
poisoning effect yeah demand is
perfectly in the one man is perfectly
elastic the firm face of perfect last so
likewise a monopolist facing a perfectly
elastic demand would also have no
poisoning effect think of it this way
what is DP DQ with perfectly last demand
zero the price doesn't change you sell
more so the reason the the perfectly
competitive firm face no poison effect
is because it's facing a it doesn't the
price doesn't have to change to sell
more units okay but a monopolist face to
poison effect because it's got a
downward sloping demand curve okay so we
can actually see this so what we want to
do in Figure eleven three is we graph
the monopolist marginal revenue curve
so let's actually work out the math here
let's imagine there's a demand curve
let's imagine that I've got a demand
curve and I'm just making this up
demands of the form Q equals 24 minus P
okay let's just say that's the demand
curve okay now the first step is to flip
the way the expresses and write this
right price a function of quantity
because now the monopolist choosing this
price so we can write the P equals 24
minus Q okay just inverting it writing
price of function of quantity okay so in
this case revenues which are equal to P
times Q are equal to 24 Q minus Q
squared I just multiply through by Q so
marginal revenues differentiating are
just 24 minus 2q okay so once again this
is a new sort of mathematical trick deal
to get used to flip the demand curves to
Express price of functional quantity
multiply through by Q and then
differentiate and you get that marginal
revenue is 24 minus 2q so you can see
that in figure 11 3 the MA
a revenue curve is the demand curve
shifted in okay now in fact this nice
relationship will not always hold this
sort of picture of a marginal revenue
curve being the demand curve shifting
will not always hold it only holds for
certain functional forms mostly we'll
use functional forints where it holds
the main lesson is the marginal revenue
curve has to be at or below the demand
curve that's the proof okay whether it
has this nice sort of shifted in
relationship that depends very much on
functional form but what is absolutely
true is the marginal revenue curve is
always everywhere at or below the demand
curve why because the demand curve
because by selling an X unit you're
gonna make less to this poisoning effect
so marginal revenue curve is always
below the demand curve alright question
about that okay so now let's go on and
let's talk about the critical
relationship I just developed intuitive
let's do it mathematically between
marginal revenue and the elasticity of
demand okay so take this um we've got
our marginal revenue expression
marginal revenue equals P plus Delta P
Delta Q times Q okay now take that
expression and multiply and divide by P
so I'm just gonna take this expression
I'm gonna multiply and divide by P okay
then I'm gonna get P plus Delta P over P
Delta Q over Q times Q over P Oh P plus
P I'm sorry nope that's wrong my bad
don't write that down I'm gonna write it
as a multiplying divided by P Pleet P
plus P times ya Delta P Delta Q times Q
over P I skipped a step okay so I just
multiplied and divided by P multiplied
divided by P P plus P times Delta Q
Delta P over Delta Q times Q over P okay
now if you look at this expression Delta
P over Delta Q times Q over P that is
the inverse of the elasticity of demand
so you can rewrite this as P plus P
times 1 over the elasticity of demand or
we're adding one more time that marginal
revenue equals P times 1 plus 1 over the
elasticity of demand marginal revenue
equals P times 1 plus 1 over the
elasticity of demand okay so think about
this for a second this gets the
intuition we just talked about if he is
if the last thing that is negative
infinite is negative infinity okay I had
it wrong with zeroth law says demands
negative infinity then you have a
competitive market perfectly competitive
market license demand negative infinity
so you get a competitive market ok as
the elasticity of demand but if the
elasticity of demand arm is zero if the
elasticity of
if the elasticity of mangos like you
less is demands negative one let's do
that case so negative infinity is
perfectly competitive okay what about
negative one what's special about the
elastic demand of negative one in this
case what's the marginal revenue zero
that's the case going back to figure
eleven to where B and C exactly cancel
out so you probably thought about this
when you loved this graph you probably
quickly ask yourself well should the
monopolist try to sell more or not well
the answer is the elastic demand is
minus one they're indifferent so this is
sort of the important insight with
elastic demand a minus one the
monopolist is indifferent about selling
another unit because what they gain from
selling unit they lose on the previous
units if the elasticity main is greater
than minus one an absolute value then
they're gonna lose money by selling
additional units if the elasticity of
demand is less than one then they're
gonna make money by by by by selling the
shown units but let's say I'm skipping
ahead let's go on and talk about profit
maximization okay so let's go on and
take the next step which is a monopoly
profit maximization imagine monopolist
cost function curve is of the form
twelve plus Q squared let's take this a
monopolist and write down cost function
of twelve plus Q squared okay so with
this cost function marginal cost equals
to Q okay that's marginal cost with this
cost function okay so what's the profit
maximization rule
it's that marginal revenue equals
marginal cost
well marginal revenue we wrote down here
is 24 minus 2q so it's where 24 minus 2q
equals marginal I should equals marginal
cost now we're not the less here's the
trick little Q and big Q are the same so
I wrote little Q here but if you're the
only firm in the market little Q and big
Q are the same right it's only one firm
in the market so 24 minus 2q equals I'll
make this a big Q now equals to Q so so
the optimization point is where 24
equals for Q or
star equals six that's the optimal
that's the profit-maximizing sale on
quantity for the monopolist is where 24
minus 2q or larger amigos marginal costs
we derive marginal revenue okay
marginal costs we know how to derive
from a cost function we set them equal
and we get the optimizing quantity okay
and you can see this in figure 11 for
figure 11 for shows what's going on here
so the I've driven all the way I've
drawn all the various cost curves for
this cost function okay I've driven all
the various cost first for this cost
function you can see the marginal cost
curve and then you can see it intersects
the marginal revenue curve at a quantity
of six intersects the marginal revenue
curve at a quantity of six okay what is
the price so we raise their hand and
tell me tell me why the quantity six
what's what's prices in monopoly set
yeah
eighteen why you're supposed to get that
wrong you didn't you didn't you didn't
follow my instruction so you can get it
wrong you got it right I'm just joking
how does you know is 18 and not twelve
usually that's 12 that's the point where
the curves intersect why is it 18 even
the monopolist as powerful as he is has
to respect demand so the monopolist is
they're gonna sell six units they have
to choose a price such that people want
to buy six units so your intuition which
is my fault I've always said look with
the curves intersect to a quantity in a
price your quick intuition which was to
look and say the price was 12 which was
the wrong answer I usually get okay it's
wrong because you need to actually
respect the demand curve so monopolist
solves for the optimal quantity but then
to get the optimum price he has to plug
this back of the main curve or what's
demand demand is 24 minus P so I'm sorry
it's P equals 24 minus Q that's our man
so if Q star is 6 then
price is 24-6 or 18 P star is 18 and
that is what you will get wrong on when
you wait to do this if you're gonna get
anything wrong I monopolies problem this
is what you're gonna get wrong okay
which is remembering you can't just at
the end you have to an extra step here
to get the price you have to solve for
quantity but then respect the demand
curve to get the price there's a
question somewhere okay yeah question
it's pretty much yes it's pretty much
meaningless basically that intersection
used to pin down the quantity but price
has to come for demand curve because you
have to respect you can't sell something
consumers don't want to buy okay so
you've got to respect that demand curve
okay and in fact you can show yourself
so so basically um okay so basically um
that's a price profit maximization
except this stupid goddamn shutdown Rule
still holds in the short-run we still
suspect the shut down world so you still
have to check its price less than
average variable cost now once again in
this function okay in this foot you have
to check if the price so even if profits
are negative you're still gonna have to
check if price is greater than average
variable cost now here at six units the
average variable cost is six you see we
can see see the dashed line if we sell
six units the average variable cost is
six so clearly price is greater than a
travel cost you wouldn't shut down
you're making positive profits in fact
you're making profits of 60 okay so you
wouldn't shut down but you always do
have to check the shutdown rule okay so
that's how you do a monopoly problem
okay just to go back how do you Monopoly
problem you'll be given a cost function
you know what to do those in your sleep
and a demand function the demand
function gets turned into marginal
revenue function simply through these
couple of steps so demand function gives
you a marginal revenue function if you
have marginal revenue of marginal
then you know how to solve for optimal
quantity if you have optimal quantity in
you respect the demand curve you know
how to solve for price once you have a
price okay and an average cost curve you
can both check the shutdown rule and
compute profits profits are simply the
price you get minus average costs so we
can compute the profit and check the
shutdown rule okay so the only thing we
did here that's new is this sort of
interesting quirk that we have this new
marginal revenue function otherwise it's
the same sort of analysis we did before
okay so this should be doable with some
practice now
the key a key concept here that we need
to think about that comes the question
you might have asked yourself at some
point you might have said well if
monopolists are the only firm in the
market why don't they just charge
whatever they want why do they have to
why are they sort of constrained by this
sort of mathematics we've done before
and to answer this let's turn to the
concept of market power the market power
of monopolist we will define as their
ability to charge price greater than
marginal cost your billing and charge
price greater than marginal cost is your
market power in other words competitive
firms have no market power they have to
charge a price that's the same as their
marginal cost and that's why they make
no money monopolist have market power
okay so now let's return to the
condition for profit maximization we
said that marginal revenue can be
rewritten as price times 1 plus 1 over
the elasticity of demand right that
equals marginal cost okay so we can
rewrite this as marginal cost over price
equals 1 plus 1 over the elasticity of
demand and this is the monopolist market
power condition so if we define the
market so we can define something we
call a markup
casually we can call profits but
technically it's the markup okay as the
percentage markup of Annapolis can make
as P minus MC over P how much of the
price is actually a markup over costs
okay sort of an intuitive concept so
basically how much of the money you get
for the unit is a markup as a share of
the money you get then that is simply
that is equal to minus one over the
elasticity of demand
so the monopolist markup is equal to one
over the minus one of your lesson demand
okay
so the elastic demand is negative
infinity that is a perfectly competitive
market then the markup is what zero just
like competitive firm competitive firms
have to charge marginal cost but as the
man gets more inelastic the monopolist
gains power to mark up the price and
make money and this answers our question
of why monopolist aren't infinitely
powerful what is the limiting factor of
monopolist it's not other firms
producing their good what's the limiting
factor a monopolist yeah yeah it's other
products so think about a monopolist and
insulin they can charge where the hell
they want right because basically
there's nothing else to buy that may be
multiple insulin products but imagine
one insulin product okay so nothing
could strange that madhabs he should
charge an infinite price up to like what
Congress will put up with okay but if
you think about a monopolist in a good
where there's a substitute so if I'm the
monopolist in gum if I'm a gum mapa list
okay then I'm constrained by what how
much people want to eventually it'll
just substitute to candy okay anything
so I'm constrained not by competitors in
my market but by the fact that consumers
can substitute to other goods so what's
the limit on monopolist consumers we're
the limit on monopolist
our willingness to put up with that good
rose to other goods ie our elasticity of
demand is the only thing limiting
monopolist okay so basically there is
market discipline innopolis even though
they're the only provider of a good they
still subject to market discipline it's
just a discipline doesn't come from
other firms it comes from consumers okay
so a great example of this is let's look
if you go on at least as of last year if
you go on Amazon and look at the prices
of two goods that you've probably had to
consume in high school Huckleberry Finn
and Great Gatsby two books okay that
many of you had to consume in high
school you had to read Huckleberry Finn
you had to drink a Greek cake the Great
Gatsby
they're both comparable lengths great
grass he's a little shorter I think but
they're both comparable lengths the
production costs the marginal cost of
producing sprite pretty comparable okay
but if you go on Amazon Huck Finn costs
four dollars and the Great Gatsby costs
$16 now why is this why is this and we
know why is Great Gatsby cost four times
much that's interesting that's not
enough to explain it's not bad enough
places fortunately to explain that what
else is going on anyone know yeah
exactly
the Great Gatsby still has copyright
protection that is only only people who
get permission from the great from
William F moon scott Fitzgerald's
descendants F scott Fitzgerald I'm
sorry's four descendants get to produce
it they have a monopoly on the good that
is the Great Gatsby Huck Finn it turns
out that 75 years after an author's
death copyright protection expires f
scott Fitzgerald hasn't been dead for 75
years
Mark Twain has sock fin can now be
produced by anyone you can go out
tomorrow and produce a copy of Huck Finn
and sell it so we think probably Huck
Finn should be produced in a pretty
competitive market that is basically the
four dollars you pay
Huck Finn should be roughly the cost of
producing a book I think I know Marcos
perfectly competitive a little market
but not much where's the Great Gatsby
it's not limited by competition but it
is limited by the fact that if they try
to charge 500 bucks for Great Gatsby
teachers would have signed something
else okay there's still a limit it's the
only 16 dollars that's not a whole lot
for one of the great works of literature
okay it's the only 16 dollars so why is
only 16 dollars because it's limited by
the fact there are other great works of
literature people can turn to so Huck
Finn is limited by the competition
within the within the market for those
across producers producing this imagines
good probably pretty close to perfectly
competitive market right it's pretty
easy to just set up a shop and produce
Huck Finn whereas the great gatsby has
this extra effect which is copyright
protected so it's only limited by by the
elasticity demand yeah that's a great
point last is demand I should say the
last thing demand for that good we're
one of the substitutes could be an
illegal substitute that's a good point
okay so let's go on and talk about the
next topic I want to cover today which
is how do we because now we have a new
set of tools we've developed that's
really cool which lets us ask the
question not just what do monopolies do
but how do we feel about it that is we
can now turn to talking about the
welfare effects of monopolies what are
the welfare effects of monopolies how do
we feel about monopolies well let's
start with the standard case that is the
case we've covered so far as opposed to
a case I'll cover in a minute
okay and let's look at figure eleven
five which is the example we just solved
for okay the example where demand equals
twenty four minus Q and cost is twelve
plus Q squared okay so here we once
again what do we do we set marginal cost
equal the marginal revenue so they sell
six units we then say what price permits
them to sell six units the price of 18
so the equilibrium is that a price of a
is that Edelen lamp Ephraim a little M
for monopoly
okay they sell six units at a price of
eighteen well at that equilibrium what's
consumer surplus it's a the area under
the demand curve above the price so
consumer surplus is area a what's
producer surplus it's B plus D the area
below the price above the supply curve
but only for the units that are sold
okay so the consumer it gets a the
producer gets B plus D okay but C plus E
is not our units that are not sold for
which the marginal for which the
willingness to pay is above the ones
supply and what do we call those units
units that are not sold some raise their
hand tell me units that are not sold for
chalupa is above the willing to supply
yeah deadweight loss
those are units that's an inefficiency
those units that are not sold that
efficiently should be that is we've
broken this our first example ever this
is a super exciting moment a breaking
the first fundamental theorem of welfare
economics the first fundamental theory
economics was that the equilibrium the
competitive equilibrium okay maximizes
welfare well that's no longer true here
we have an equilibrium that comes out of
competition okay it's what the market
delivers but it doesn't maximize welfare
there's a deadweight loss and that's
because the markets imperfectly
competitive this is our first ever
example of what we call a market failure
okay and that's what from my perspective
makes economics fund okay there were no
market failures if all markets function
the way we said they function then
basically we could have been largely
done with the course by now okay what
makes us all interesting is markets
don't function the way we said they
function in that extreme case and
therefore markets a market failure is
defined as a case where the market
equilibrium does not maximize social
welfare so whenever the market
equilibrium does not maximize social
welfare you've got a market failure in
the perfectly competitive case we didn't
have a failure because the market like a
little B maximize welfare that's not
true here now the market equilibrium
does not maximize welfare therefore it's
a market failure hint what's exciting
about that to me is that means there
might be potential role for policy okay
so far in this course the government's
just been a bad guys they're nothing but
set mean minimum wages and things like
that
and terrible price ceilings but in fact
as we'll see next time this starts to
introduce the role for the government's
a good guy okay now what makes two
drives intuition will make this more
interesting let's contrast that to the
more realistic case of price
discrimination or potentially more
realistic case of price discrimination
now what happens if we don't force the
monopolist to only charge one price what
if we allow the monopolist to charge
different prices to different consumers
here's a cool conclusion actually kind
of crazy conclusion if
monopolist can perfectly price
discriminate
that is they can sell a separate price
for every consumer then monopoly is
welfare maximizing if monopolist could
set a perfect price for every consumer
then monopoly does maximize social
welfare to see that simply look at
figure eleven six now let's take a
perfectly price-discriminating
monopolist let's think about what this
prices they said well essentially what
they're going to do is set price where a
perverse criminai monopolist is going to
set the price for each unit to what yeah
the demand the willingness to pay if
you're perfectly price-discriminating
you will screw consumers to the max and
how do you do that by delivering them no
surplus by taking all the surplus for
yourself so for the first unit you
charge five for the second unit you
charge for and for the sixth unit you
charge 18 now
her sweat streaming up now the priest
monopolist stopped at six why do we stop
at six because the cell the seventh unit
would have lost the money he would have
had to lower the price in all previous
units but the price humanopolis has no
poisoning effect because he doesn't have
to lower the price on the previous units
he can say for that seventh unit I'm
gonna sell that one at seventeen I'm
gonna make seventeen I'm not gonna lose
any money because I can keep the other
prices the same so the perfectly
price-discriminating monopolist you get
rid of the poisoning effect thing just
marched their way down the demand curve
charging every consumer exactly their
willingness to pay therefore they will
continue to produce until the
competitive equilibrium they will
continue to proves until willingness to
pay equals willing to supply but they
will capture all the surplus so the new
equilibria will be EC the competitive
equilibrium but the entire surplus goes
to the monopolist so the fascinating
case there's we maximize social welfare
but only because we define social off in
this peculiar way which is the simple
sum of consumer producer surplus here
producers get all the surplus therefore
welfare is maximized so perfectly price
is crating monopolist okay gets back
some eyes social welfare okay now
there's two interesting points that come
out of this okay point one is this is a
cool way to understand why does the
deadweight loss for monopoly it's cool
to understand because you can see you
can focus on that point East sub N and
think about why the perfectly price
scrim innopolis gets to sell another
unit and the regular monopolist doesn't
because the regular monopolist has the
poison effect and the perfectly
price-discriminating monopolist does not
so it's a good way to sort of think
about that intuition of the poisoning
effect that's lesson one lesson two is
gee we may want to think about
definition of welfare that's not just a
sum of consumer producer surplus a model
of welfare that delivers the fact that a
producer that can screw every single
consumer out of any of their surplus is
the best possible outcome might not be a
model we're so happy with okay but that
we can come back to but for now it's a
nice extreme and in fact in reality no
firm is heard
price-discriminating okay Amazon tried
to be there was a controversy number
years ago where Amazon would set your
price according to your what's a little
string a numbers address IP address they
literally would set prices by IP address
they'd literally say well you know
you're coming for an IP address that's
for example you're in a high high income
area I'm gonna charge you more you're in
a university therefore you need this
book for a course therefore I'm gonna
charge you more etc that they got busted
and that was found illegal but just
because you can't perfectly price
discriminate
doesn't mean we don't have lots of
examples of partial price discrimination
so what are examples in the real world a
price discrimination what if firms do
and what's the general let me ask the
the tell me what friends do and also
mono what's the general principle what's
the basic idea that firms if you want to
price discriminate what do you want to
figure out what is your goal to figure
out yeah everybody the elasticity is low
because they have to go if you're gonna
buy two days before you got to go okay
if you're buying six months before you
know you might have to go that day you
might not have to go that day you might
have to but if you're buying last minute
you got to go so your elasticity is
lower so price-discriminating monopolist
look for signals of elasticity that's
their search there's they can't
literally no your willingness to pay
amazon tried but even amazon couldn't
perfectly no your willingness to pay so
they're looking for signals that are
correlated with your willingness to pay
one signal is whether you want to fly at
the last minute that means you have a
low elasticity you're screwed you got to
go what's another thing airlines do
what's another signal of alaska see the
airline juice
how else yeah they don't I don't know if
I actually use that how long you been
the website they could that'd be kind of
interesting
yeah I don't know but but that that's
pretty subtle what's the more blunt one
they use even before websites so ya know
even before search I know you guys go
for the Internet but there was life
before the internet and even before the
internet Airlines price discriminator
what did they what did they do in the
back yeah yeah different levels of
flight right why is a first-class ticket
more than a coach ticket because rich
guys are less elastic than poor guys
okay so basically another way of price
discriminating within the same flight is
by having different quality so what they
do is they say we're gonna give you a
higher quality product but look
first-class business so I flew business
class for the first time my life was
very excited went to India flew business
class it was awesome
okay but it raised the price taken from
a thousand a twenty five hundred now it
was better but it wasn't fifteen hundred
dollars better okay or certain Lim put
this let me sit Meuse rephrase that
it costs more but it still didn't cost
fifteen hundred dollars more I got a
bigger seat and like you know people
slaved over me but like it certainly did
not cost them fifteen hundred dollars to
bribe that service they clearly made
more of a markup on the business class
seat than they did in the coach seat
because I was less elastic why cuz
someone else is paying for my flight
okay so I was less elastic and that's if
you talk to people in business class not
I'm gonna paying for their own flights
they were they're super rich or other
companies paying okay so the bottom line
that's another way online scripted so
let's get away from Airlines what are
other examples of price discrimination
yeah
I think I have to look this up I think
they're not allowed to do that they're
allowed to that in targeting advertising
but I don't know if they'll I did it in
setting the price I don't know a company
glad to do that setting the price yeah
exactly
or that's exactly right restaurants are
supermarkets now here's what's
interesting if you look at McDonald's
okay its prices I know this is true for
both basically if you look like like if
if I buy make when I buy McDonald's on
the highway out in the suburbs it's more
expensive than I buy here in Cambridge
why is that why why is why is a big so
yeah yeah I'm like I'm driving where am
I gonna go I can't say oh it's too
expensive going next door so that's an
example inner-city pricing our
supermarkets charge much higher prices
in the city than out of the city they
might think that's sort of strange okay
but that's because in the city people
have to walk to get their don't have a
lot of options there's not a lot of
shopping I would say they can drive from
supermarket - supermarket okay so
there's all these complicated things
that go into it one of my let me sort of
show you my couple of my favorite
examples one of my favorite examples is
early bird specials now you guys might
not know about this but you might have
hung out with your grandparents and
known that like if you go to a
restaurant sometimes before five o'clock
or 5:30 it's cheaper or if you go to
Matt and Alma if you go to matinee movie
a movie during the day is cheaper than a
movie at night say movie why why is a
movie during the day cheaper than a
movie at night yeah
you're purposely looking for cheaper
options you're more elastic during the
day because basically you're an old
retired person's got nothing but time in
their hands it's like you can shop
around movie theatres you can decide to
go the movie or take a nap etc okay
same thing with early dinner specials
people who have more time to shop are
more elastic at night you're going out
to see the movie these are people you
know in some sense it's sort of
interesting you think midnight movies I
don't this is true midnight movie should
charge in most of all because that's a
bunch of insane fans right you have to
see the movie first seems like the
midnight showing should charge the most
I don't know if that's true that'd be
interesting to look at okay that's one
example another example I love is
Disneyland Disneyland and Disney World
charge less if you live within 20 or so
miles of the park
why because you can go whenever so when
I took my kids to Disney World if I want
to set oh I'm sorry kids was ten dollars
one I thought we're not going okay when
how to ride it on my hands
once you're there you're inelastic
you're going to Disney World
it's nothing else to do in Orlando I
mean but there's other parks I guess but
like but if you live locally you can
decide you to go or not okay and then
probably the most interesting recent
example is Tesla so during did I tell
you guys to test the hurricane story yet
I don't think so right
okay so during the hurricane in Florida
Parham I guess it was in Florida Tesla
so Tesla sold two cars two models the
cheaper model the more expensive model
and the more expensive model has some
nice doodads but most importantly the
end the battery lasted longer the
cheaper models like 300 miles the more
expensive models like 500 miles during
hurricane Emma Tesla as a good gesture
of goodwill
okay said hey guys who drives a cheap
car you can now drive 500 miles and
they're like what the hell it's the same
battery Tesla said well it turns out
it's the it's the same battery the owner
is a piece of software that we could
turn off our on so why did Tesla do that
why did Tesla have a piece of software
they turn off our on and turn it off for
some people to make them drive less why
did they do that there's someone else
involved can anyone tell me about what
Tesla saw besides you I must be an
[ __ ] what else what's the other
what's the kind of what what sort of
Tesla's thought process actually was
perfect economics Yeah right price
information but how how you price
screaming by making some people yeah
more expensive exactly it's like first
class your base is saying I want to
charge more for a better product I can't
charge more for the same product so if I
give everyone five hundred miles
I can't charge more but by making one
product better I can separate demand I
could sell the expensive practical about
lowlifes to demand consumers and the
less expensive the high elasticity
demand but it's actually the same damn
product I just did it as a way to price
discriminate so Tesla an effort to be
nice secure screwed themselves by
revealing that they had been actually
falsely screw you know screwing
consumers it's not stuck it's good
economics it makes total sense okay this
actually follows one last example when
the first laser printers came out okay
it turned out that you could buy one for
home that was like half the prices one
for office and someone took them apart
and found the one for home was the one
for the office plus an extra piece that
made it go slower okay and they did that
simply because they knew the office guys
were less price elastic than the home
guys
so what an expensive one so they said
the office ones faster isn't this cool
was fast slow because they didn't add an
extra piece that made it go slower okay
and that's the same thing so let's stop
there and we'll come back and talk more
monopoly good luck tomorrow night and
we'll talk more about monopoly on
Wednesday